hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast studying environmental sensing
in response in a bacterial plant
pathogen inside out presented by and
Stevens professor of microbiology
Department of Biological Sciences
Virginia Tech I'm Alexis Krause of lab
birds and I will be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
this educational web seminar presented
by lab rats lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before you begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
it respond to your questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Stephens
I will now turn the presentation over to
her hello everyone thank you for
participating today
and I'm glad to join you and discuss the
work in my lab on environmental sensing
and response in the bacterial plant
pathogen on this first slide here you
see a number of small young corn plants
on the far left is a healthy corn plant
as you move from the left to the right
you'll see a series of plants showing
increased disease due to wilt and on the
far right of course is a plant that has
died from wolf disease we've studied
bacterial pathogen the cause of this
well disease the bacteria
can'twe us to RDI subspecies Guardia
it is a gram-negative rod in the intro
bacteria is a family and it has a
characteristic yellow pigment as you can
see from the colonies in the circular
inside of must slide it is the causative
agent of Stuart's wilt disease and the
principle host that is damaged by the
spectral pathogen is maize particularly
to sweet corn popcorn varieties field
corn varieties often have been bred
resistance to it the disease's primarily
transmitted to the young corn plants by
the corn flea beetle this beetle is
native to North America thus the disease
is most prevalent in North America in
particular in the Midwestern states and
mid-atlantic states seed corn has to be
screened for presence of the bacterium
to prevent its dissemination on a global
scale if you look in the bottom series
of pictures what you see on the far left
is a corn flea beetle on a leaf of a
corn plant the beetle scratches the
surface of the leaf during next feeding
and then it defecates them to the bloom
and in this manner the bacteria are
introduced from the intestinal tract of
the beetle into the a palast of the leaf
tissue and the next panel to the right
what you can see is the first stages of
the disease result in water soaking
lesions the bacterium encodes a type 3
secretion system and releases effectors
into the plant cells that produce this
characteristic streaking and the crisis
of the plant tissue as the disease
progresses as you see in the panel 3 the
bacteria moved from the AVA plants that
the leaf tissue into the xylem where
they form a thick biofilm
the Spile some blocks water flow and
ends up producing wilt as you see on the
far right hand panel which can cause
damage to crop production and are
ultimately dots in the case of some
plants particularly if they're
inoculated
with bacteria emotional seedlings the
beetle will be feed on infected corn
plants and thus the lifecycle of the
bacterium can be continued and the
incidence of disease in corn is
proportional to the survival of the
beetles over the winter so the bacterium
over winters within the intestinal tract
of the flea beetle the biome that is the
primary cause of wilt is a process that
is controlled by bacterial warm sensor
the process of corn sensing is
widespread amongst the number of the
bacteria and the principle of it is
shown in the slide the large yellow
circles represent bacterial cells and
the smaller more named circles represent
signals that are produced by the
bacterial cells when you have a
bacterial population growing at a low
cell density it has produced a low
quantity of these signals however as the
concentration of the population rises
its density increases the popula or the
concentration of the signal also
proportionally increases this allows the
bacterial cells to behave as a
coordinated unit and to express
phenotypes of importance to them in a
concerted manner the process of quorum
sensing was first identified in the
number of bioluminescent marine bacteria
where it controls bioluminescence and
then it was subsequently found that a
number of pathogens used for sensing to
control expression of virulence factors
and so what this allows the bacteria to
do is to I first enter the host
underneath the host defenses build up a
population and then as a coordinated
unit
express all the various factors as a
coordinated group population to be more
successful in invading the host so
biofilm formation and hence where's the
where di is controlled by quorum sensing
this slide shows you the signal that is
produced by plants where
where they are and there's an acyl
homoserine lactone molecule and a
structure showed here a specific
molecule is 3x an allele homoserine
lactone interestingly this is the same
quorum sensing molecule that is the
primary autoinducer or acyl homoserine
lactone produced by the bioluminescent
bacteria Vibrio fischeri a protein
called Issa eyes autoinducer rhl
someplace and it produces this point of
sensing signal and there is another
important protein ista are that senses
the signal and it's the master point
sensing regulator it is a transcription
factor that combines two promoters of
control expression of a number of genes
and responds to warm sensing work in a
number of labs has identified that for
instance an intense waste where they are
controls capsule production the capsule
and can't waste where di is actually
known as the Waterman and that's
important to the bio information it's
also known that poor innocence and
controls surface mobility also important
files on formation and of course then
the biofilm is important shoe
Iria lens in addition to this there are
other various factors also produced by
Penn to Astoria that are not under
constants in control this includes its
pigment production molecule support for
iron acquisition a cyclic lytic toxin
and other stress responses and a lot of
this work has been performed in the labs
of Suzanne by Woodman and Caroline
rubber today I wanted to talk more about
the quorum sensing response of Trance
waste where they are and so the way this
system works is actually quite novel in
most core sensing systems such as that a
marine Vibrio fischeri the regulatory
protein becomes functional at high cell
density in other words when the own
inducer concentration builds up that's
when we get a fax of gene expression the
freshly regulated in the case of pentas
pathways where it's the opposite the
regulatory
tene actually binds to the DNA in the
absence of the AHL signal and this is
what you can see in the green inset here
so at low so Nestle's Issa are combined
to the promoters that it regulates if it
binds in the position near -10 it's
going to repress expression of the gene
downstream of that promoter and if it
binds more upstream stay at the position
there - where two and a half it's going
to serve as an activator and enhance
gene expression when the population
switches to a high cell density the aho
actually renders the East are
approaching non-functional it's no
longer able to bind to the DNA so you
get a reverse of the gene expression
patterns that you saw under love so
densely so genes that were initially
repressed now become D repressed or
expressed and genes that were initially
activated that loves eventually are now
deactivated at high cell density this
type of porn sensing system allows the
bacteria to precisely coordinate the
timing of subsets of genes both at low
cell density and high cell density and
we know that this is critically
important to the success of pants way as
it is causing disease in plants if you
have mutants that are incapable of
performing or in something they are a
virulent and also if you have
constitutively expressed for instance
assistance to the point sends that
system is always on the temporal
expression of the genes is not correct
and so the biofilm conform to girly and
this also renders the strength a
virulent my lab was interested in
understanding more about some of the
direct targets of the East our protein
and how global decorum sensing responses
in less bacterium so prior to starting
this work it was known that these are
controlled council production my lab
performed two studies we performed a
proteomic level analysis where we looked
at what proteins were expressed at high
cell density under during
for I'm sensing the muscle density
compared to most of that city and we
also looked at the transcriptome that
was regulated by section and so the
majority but not all of the genes that
we identified here this diagram is
focused on three groups of genes that we
found had similar related functions we
found that ISA IRA was regulating a
number of genes associated with stress
responses this would be expected as the
bacterium is going to encounter host
defenses that are going to create stress
on it as the plant is trying to fight
off the infection in addition we found
genes important for spell and below the
capsule synthesis and this had been
predicted because it wasn't already
known the capsule production was under
the control of form sensing
we also found genes associated with
surface motility and adhesion and so
there are two genes that particularly
caught our attention that was the gene
our CSA which is a transcription factor
associated with controlling capsule
production and LR action which is a
transcription factor associated with
controlling surface motility and so
through a number of studies in our lab
we were able to develop a better
understanding of the interplay between
the regulatory factors isa our our SES
AML Rho and so as you can see in this
diagram you are when it's active at low
cell density actually Auto represses
itself it also represses our csa this
prevents our CSA from act activating
capsule production at low cell density
in addition isa are itself coordinately
controls some of the targets under our
csa regulation and represses them
further preventing capsule would be
formed at too early of a stage during
the bacterial growth
isa are activates LRH a which serves as
a repressor for itself for our csa and
for a number downstream
it's that are associated with surface
motility and Issa are also coordinate Li
controls some of those same targets by
repressing them thus from RCS a you can
see there's a type 2 feed-forward loop
from a Llorente there's a tight squeeze
before with it when the cell density
reaches not a high concentration isaw
will become inactivated so it will no
longer repress our csa or its downstream
targets that will no longer activate
laha or repress that's downstream
targets thus what now happens is LRH a
it is no longer expressed so it's you
get D repression of its targets an RCS a
is expressed and you get expression of
its targets leading to capsule
production all of the work that I've
described to you up to this point was
done in vitro and liquid or plate
culture and so we have a strong interest
and actually trying to understand what
is actually going on inside the plant so
we decided to look inside out by
performing in plans of studies and
determining what was occurring as pant
whale was progressing through its stages
of infection the plan specifically we
focused at the Zion stage of the
infection when the bacteria are at high
cell density and we decided to use a
global level analysis the first
procedure that we did is something
called RNA sequencing in their RNA
secret short in our experimental design
as shown here in this diagram we grew
the bacterial cells three different ways
we grew them in planta as you can see on
the left we also grew them and shoot in
vitro conditions in the middle you can
see we grew them on a low nutrient agar
medium we were hoping that this would to
some degree mimic the high that's a weak
growth of the bacteria within the xylem
by allowing the bacteria to grow to a
highest on
the unloader media and on the far right
you can see we grew the bacterium liquid
culture and this liquid culture serves
as the pre inoculum for infecting the
plants easy nose island infection model
so we harvested DNA from in planta from
the plate and from the pre inoculum
liquid culture we purified the RNA and
then we used it for two types of
experiments RNA sequencing in
quantitative reverse transcription PCR
an overview of the RNA seek approaches
given here as I mentioned we start with
total RNA that we extract from your
environment of interest we then not next
depleted the ribosomal RNA as this is
the majority of the RNA recovered from
bacterial cells initially this allowed
us to enrich for the messenger RNA that
we were most interested in study we then
converted those messenger RNAs into a
cDNA library which underwent
next-generation Illumina sequencing and
produce transcription rates that were
could be correlated with different genes
across the genome we used but then
available in complete genome of Ken
Twista where di to align our sequencing
reads to the annotated genes of the
genome and then we followed this with
some bioinformatics analysis using
genius to map the genes through the
genome and then perform subsequent data
analysis this is the type of output that
we were able to produce
we had approximately 30 million reads
from each one of our samples and we were
able to compare the level of gene
expression in plaintiff versus our two
in vitro growth conditions so in the top
and panel a you see in planta versus the
pre inoculum liquid gene expression and
then the lower panel BC the implant
versus the plate grown cells an inch one
of those diagrams you'll see a green
line any dots above the green line
either gray or
represent genes that were expressed or
sold or higher in plants so these are
genes whose expression is activated when
the bacteria are grown inside the plant
the red line represents the fourfold or
below cutoff for genes that are
repressed so any gray or red dots below
that red line our genes that are
repressed when the bacteria are grown
inside the plant so you can see that the
majority of the genes were not
differentially regulated but in all we
had over 500 genes representing about
10% of the genome that was
differentially expressed to
independently validate these results
from the iron a seek we wanted to
perform a qrt-pcr analysis and so for
that analysis we picked a subset of
genes and the colored dots that you see
on the diagram are the genes that we
selected so we selected seven sorry
eight genes that were activated in
planta two genes that were replaced
repressed in planta
and the three black dots represent
constitutively expressed genes that we
were able to use as a control and our
qrt-pcr analysis the workflow that we
perform for this qrt-pcr shown here so
we selected our genes of interest as i
just mentioned and we first cloned them
into the PMT vector this allowed us to
purified DNA template of a known
quantity so that we could optimize our
primers to an efficiency of binding
between 90 and 110 percent
we then separately reenact elated our
bacteria in two plants we isolated the
RNA and then performed qrt-pcr on the
cDNA that was amplified from that total
RNA and calculated the relative
transcript expression levels using the
method our results are shown here what
you see on the left are the genes that
were activated in plants and either in
comparison
to the liquid clincher panel on the top
or to the plate panel see on the bottom
on the right hand side of the diagram
are the two genes that were repressed in
planta again panel be on the top
representing the comparison to the
liquid growth and penalty on the bottom
and in comparison to the playground cult
row the point bars in all of these
panels represent the data from the iron
Asetek analysis and the black bars
represent the data from the qrt-pcr
analysis which you can see is the
absolute values are not exact which is
not what you would expect given the high
sensitivity of these methods especially
but qrt-pcr is a logarithmic progression
and so it can generate significant error
but the overall trends hold up
consistently and so and there's
confirmed to us that our findings for
the iron a secret were indeed correct
since we had independently validated the
results for these 10 genes this gave us
confidence to move forward in our
analysis of the iron a stigmata and so
we've performed a gene ontology analysis
shown here the top panel again shows the
results from implants a culture
comparisons the liquid culture and the
bottom panel shows the implant
culture compared to the plate culture in
both cases the red bars represent genes
that were highly repressed and the green
bars represent genes that were highly
activated and so this bioinformatic
approach clusters genes of related
function together so that you can see
trends in your data and what immediately
stood out to us was a high number of
transporter genes that are activated in
plaintiff whether we compare it to the
broth culture which is the plate culture
the transporters that were upregulated
included large numbers of those four
amino acids including Elleni arginine
spark
glue them a histidine isoleucine lysine
mainly and sugars such as arabinose
galactose ribose and xylose and we saw a
few other interesting transporters
upregulated including those for ammonium
magnesium molybdate sulfate and higher
twice a couple of transcription factors
also show associated with control of
transport so clearly plan is of creating
an environment that triggers the
bacteria to significantly up regulate
its transport functions in addition
another highly up regulated group of
proteins where the oxidation reduction
process is written and this encompasses
a wide variety of genes one of the genes
upregulated was cytochrome d the
suggests that the bacteria are facing a
micro era silicon vironment inside the
xylem of the plant
there were also stress response
functions upregulated such as such as
superoxide dismutase and nitric oxide
outside dioxygen thanks and
interestingly some redox processes
associated with metabolism also fell
into this category so we saw an
upregulation and fatty acid metabolism
and glyoxylate cycle genes suggesting
the shift in the metabolic profile and
and we saw a number of other metabolic
dehydrogenases that were regulated as
well so collectively what we've learned
from the RNA seek analysis was that one
can't waste where di is in a biofilm in
the xylem of planet high so density it
is up regulating a large number of
nutrient transporters especially those
associated with sugars and amino acids
it's a breaking landing
stress responses presumably in response
to host designs and it's all trading its
metabolism and so our hypothesis is that
pant waste where d is responding to
implant nutrient availability host
defenses with the expression of specific
genes in response to do that environment
what we
do not know is yet is if the nutrients
available in this island are always
present or if the bacterium is actually
altering the hosts metabolism to its
benefit and my collaborator
I don't highest State University David
Mackey is exploring the specific
questions through metabolomic Spelling's
that excuse me metabolomic studies which
we hope to coordinate with these
transcriptome studies another
interesting finding not stated here but
something that we observed on RNA seek
is that the type 3 secretion system was
also up regulated and this was a little
bit surprising because it was thought
that that was only important in the
April plan stages infraction so we were
able to complete the RNA seek analysis
using the genome sequence that was
available to us at that time but it was
quite a challenge because it was an
incomplete genome and it was in a number
of contexts and quite complicated and
difficult to work with so so that we
could do additional genome-wide level
analysis my lab decided to finish the
genome assembly of can't where's de la
di and we did this using alumina mate
mate pair sequencing with an insert size
of 3500 base pairs to help us get across
highly repetitive regions in the genome
once the genome was assembled we were
able to determine either those 5.3
kilobase Pearson sides it consists of
one circular chromosome and ten circular
plasmids one very interesting thing we
found about the plasmids but the two of
these plasmids each encode a type 3
secretion system one of the plasmids
encodes a type 3 secretion system but
specifically you just utilize during the
plant infection and another plasmid
encodes a completely separate type 3
secretion system that has been shown to
be important for its maintenance within
the intestinal tract of the cornflake
people
addition to these plasmids one linear
phase was identified and in the end we
found that the genome had over 400
highly repetitive transpose a sequences
and this is likely what was contributing
to the difficulty in assembling the
genome for such a long time using this
complete genome we were able to move on
to another type of analysis called
transposon sequencing TN seek for short
this is a method that has actually been
used quite a bit in animal model systems
but our work is one of the first studies
where TN seek has actually been applied
to be used in the plant system and so
the this approach is outlined in this
diagram that I borrowed from a nature
review we first generate a transposon
library in your organism of interest in
our case we use the Mariner base
transposon system and used it to create
a library of 40,000 different mutants of
pantywaist where di that mutant library
is then used to inoculate under the
gross conditions that you're interested
in testing so condition a in our case
was a liquid grown Ross culture of
pantywaist where di and in our case
condition B was not a mouse but of
course it was juvenile corn plant or
young corn slated seedling so you allow
the bacteria with the transposon
mutations to occupy these two
environments and then you extract the
DNA out of bacterial cells after they've
grown in those environments for the same
number of generations and you sequence
the DNA and look for what transposons
were able to survive for which
transposon meet the strains were able to
survive and the host versus which ones
were eliminated how do you interpret
this information is shown better in this
slide and hopefully this will make it a
little bit clearer so the top half of
the slide is the control library so this
would be a culture that we grew in
liquid laws and
have four condition B would be your test
library for us this would be the implant
for growth conditions what you see
looking them at the top condition a is
focusing here on three example genes
genes a B and C and in mutant one gene a
had the transposon meat in it in me and
two gene B had the transposon be an
Indian three James C and the transposon
unit the reads that we get from
sequencing of the DNA extracted from our
samples gives us read counts that are
aligned to the annotated genes and those
are represented by the red bars so which
you can see is that there were a number
of reads associated with transposons
within gene a and within gene B however
if you look immediately above G and C
you can see there are no red bars and so
what this indicates is that we recovered
no transpose ons that were existed in
gene C this is because as you can see on
the right even 3 was absent from the
population that acids with our in vitro
growth conditions they could not survive
because genes C is essential in most
birth conditions you of course are going
to take a control library to them
inoculate into your your host plant and
so new 3 never entered a plant model
system because it was essential in vitro
it could not survive we could not grow
it and therefore it could not be tested
in plants a book whose already gone for
my transpose on cool so now we're
looking at just gene a and gene B and so
if you compare the expand umber and
reads associated with gene a under
condition a in vitro and condition be
implanted you can say see that there was
a significant reduction in the number of
transposon reads found in gene a in
planta and so again if you look on the
far right your conclusion there's is
that mutant one containing the
transposon here than GA is less abundant
was eliminated from the in plans of
population because gene a must speak it
conditionally essentially important
implant in our test conditions if you
look at gene be carefully what you see
is there were a number of reads
associated with to be in vitro but if
you look at condition B the number of
reads actually increased it didn't
decrease so Mewtwo survived very well in
planta and against our conclusion from
Alyssa's mutant to is more abundant
because Mutai students and gene B
actually allow those cells containing
that mutation to have better Fitness
which is survived better implant them
and we found both of these types of
results when we looked at our data which
I'll get into in just a minute here this
is the overall workflow of our study
design and so as I mentioned earlier we
made a mariner transposon library
containing 40,000 muse we picked this
number based on the idea that we needed
to be below what's called the bottleneck
the bible milk is a critical issue and
design and transposon speak studies
because whenever you introduce a certain
number of bacteria into a host organism
not all of them are actually going to
successfully be able to get into the
host and survive and so we did
preliminary experiments to determine
what was the efficiency that pantywaist
where di could actually enter into the
coin xylem and we found that it was
about 10 percent therefore when we
inoculated the plants we actually
inoculated them with about 10 to the 6
colony forming units knowing that about
10 to the fifth bacteria would actually
be able to successfully enter into the
xylem and this number was above the
40,000 level that we used in our library
that way we ensured to all
40,000 of our mutants should have been
able to enter the plant and therefore
this would not bias our study we grew
this mutant library overnight and
they'll be so cultured it in ellaby to
create a pre inoculum liquid culture and
an infected 30 plants with that same
culture and I agree the plants for six
days and we estimated that the growth
NLB between the liquid and the sub
culture and the growth in the plants
came out to roughly the same number of
generations so we extracted our DNA and
then performed next generation Illumina
sequencing and came up with recounts
associated with the transposons within
our various strains that had survived
under the different conditions so in
this diagram a blue dot represents the
recount level of a specific single gene
in panel a what you see is a comparison
of our two in vitro conditions we
perform this experiment and duplicate
you can see us there's a very tight
linear correlation all the data falls
along a fairly straight line with
greater scattering of jeans with
recounts less than 10 due to the fact
that the recounts are so low the
statistical error begins to increase in
the results in panel B we compared the
two and plant a growth condition so what
you can see is again the data points
follow along a linear pattern but
there's much more scatter and this has
to do with the fact that we're dealing
with less controlled environment being
implanted and we also are dealing with
potential bottleneck issues that did not
exist the me in vitro culture we believe
all 40,000 of our mutants we're in there
but it caused us to get lower numbers of
recounts so for example in LB we're
getting a great more than a million
reads per sample whereas in plants that
we were getting on the order of 300 to
500 thousand reads per sample because of
differences
between the samples we decided not to
average our data but we instead did a
pairwise comparison and that is shown in
panel C and D so we took one in vitro
sample compared it to one it plans a
sample and then repeated that for the
second sample and then looks the
consistent patterns between those two
data analyses so this information was
underwent a lot of bioinformatics
analysis and our findings are summarized
here so for the LB grunt library we
found that there were 169 genes just
growing in lb for which we could recover
no recounts so we consider these genes
to be absolutely essential for growth
and Albee of these 169 G and 71 encoded
hypothetical proteins for which there is
no annotated function on top of this
there were an under 406 genes that gave
us incredibly low recounts between 0 and
10 across both of the LD samples and so
we also consider that these genes are
probably very very important for
survival Justin Lee in vitro those
conditions and therefore their
quantities were going to be restricted
entering the plant so when we considered
which genes to analyze from the implant
analysis we used 3528 genes and all of
these genes had reached every counts
greater than 10 from the LB library when
we looked in planta what we found was
that were there were almost 500 genes
that appeared to be very important for
implanted growth and survival
these were genes that had more than 10
fold lower read recounts in planta
versus the LD control
so the mutant was carrying transposons
and those genes were not able to survive
well in planta we did have a small
number of genes to be precise that
actually were from strains that gained
better fitness in plant tha than in the
lb and four of these genes were
associated with regulate
council production ICS a b c and d and
two hypothetical proteins of unknown
function so for the capsule producing or
regulating functions the somewhat makes
sense to us because capsule costs the
cell a lot of energy if all of your
neighbors and the population they're
already making capsule and you can save
energy by borrowing capsule sum that
would essentially be a cheater you can
save energy and survive better than your
neighbors that are expending energy to
make this capsule we wanted to again
perform a secondary analysis to validate
some of our results and so we picked a
number of genes to perform additional
implants of validations for this we
picked two genes that we already had in
my library LRH a which again in comes a
transcription in the factory regulating
service not solely in IRCs they then
because of transcription factor regular
capsule production and then in addition
we picked three genes that we found to
have very very low recounts in planta
this included on c and clip codes a
general for horns our outer membrane
proteins that are important for
controlling the fusion of small
molecules across the outer membrane
Banaras also are regulated in response
to external stresses especially osmotics
dresses ma was another outer membrane
protein that we found to be highly
upregulated in planta and interestingly
outer membrane proteins have been
associated to be various factors and
some other animal models the third gene
we picked was Lon Lon encodes pretty ace
and this would be important for stress
responses the first acid that we
performed was a competition pass a and
what we did was we wanted to analyze our
five mutant strains so the genes at the
bottom we test the deletions in those
genes and we could ask how could those
mutants
compete in a one-to-one ratio with the
wildtype strength so if a gene mutation
enhances the fitness of the mutant the
Fitness is going to out-compete the
wild-type and that is what you see for
our CSA and that is what we had
predicted so the relative competitive
index for the deletion in our CSA was
greater than 10 it out computed the
wild-type again presumably because it
did not have to make capsule it was
cheating and taking capsule from the
wild-type cells around them that were
expending energy to make the capsule a
gene that is detrimental to survival in
plants that will have the relative
competitive index less than one and so
you can see this clearly for antsy and
lon and so what this did is it confirmed
our team seek analysis but if you have a
mutation and on C or a mutation than lon
those mutants are less able to compete
against the wild-type and they will be
eliminated from the population of the
time Ellery J had a competitive index of
exactly one and this was not surprising
to us as we were not predicting that it
would really be an advantage or a
disadvantage for the cell to have a
deletion of our HJ based on our TMC
catalysis the one result that did not
meet our expectations or our predictions
was the deletion and as you can see the
deletion in host a actually competed
better than the wild-type er and even
predicted the opposite it would have
been a disadvantage we hypothesize that
perhaps this was due to the fact that in
the tenancy Canales you have a mixed
population of thousands of mutants and
the aim you and there was a very small
fractional population so we repeated
these competition assays of the ratio of
one to mine with the on baby and at a
lower ratio than before but we observe
the same results so we don't know if we
we changed the ratio even more we might
see result or there might be some other
explanation for the spy needs such as
some kind of unknown polar effects
on our on the mutant in the tennessee
Canales that led to some of our flying
readings but because of this we decided
we wanted to perform another analysis
just to see if we could see any
phenotype attributed to the haunting you
and so we performed classic plant abuse
assays so we use the xylem inspection
model to inoculate young quartz corn
seedlings with pure cultures of our
different strains of interest and then
we scored the disease severity so a
score of zero means you have a very
healthy vibrant non diseased plant
whereas a score of five in the case of
the plant as bad due to wilt disease and
so sorry didn't last what you see is our
negative control the phosphate buffered
saline gave us no disease symptoms
whereas the wild type strain gave us a
disease or of three indicating
intermediate or fairly high because
these levels if you look at our three
mutants the deletions are on C on a and
lon you can see that they all had the
decreased virulence and this decreased
virulence was the statistically
significant for deletion and Ave and the
deletion in law so these genes are
important for causing disease in the
plant I'm C was also decreased and it
just barely missed their statistical
cutoff so we believe it also does play
an important role in disease the other
three bars that you see are the
complementation strains for the various
means and they all to varying degrees
increased the disease score and they
were all statistically equivalent to the
wild-type so in conclusion what we all
have learned from our TN seek analysis
so far is that we were able to identify
over 500 genes that are important for
growth in vivo in the plant and we also
identified genes that are just important
for in vitro ll be grown conditions as
well but of course our interest was the
ones that were important in the plant we
selected five of these genes to perform
some initial
plant assays and we have established new
roles where the genes on to the aman and
the ability of pants where the aides to
grow and survive in the plant and the
ability of on a and lon - honey we in
the future would like to investigate
additional genes that we identified by
our team seek analysis and we'd like to
perform a second TMC Canales by studying
the early stages of pantywaist where di
infection of the leaf maple class in
collaboration with our colleague david
mackay overall these findings are giving
us a broader understanding of the
bacterium's lifestyle and corn and we
hope ultimately might in the future lead
to some possible disease disease
intervention strategies I'd like to
briefly conclude by acknowledging that
when I say we it is they my students
that have done the work so I have three
past graduate students Allison and
bravely that performs much of the work
and Holly Packard as well who's still a
current student whom allow working with
undergraduate students brandy Thomas and
chase Mullins I want to thank our
collaborators rec Jensen who's our
bioinformatician and David Mackey Ohio
State and of course our funding sources
and I'll be happy to respond to
questions that you send them thank you
for your time today
thank you dr. Stephens for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question jot down box located on the far
left to your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is what is known
about the growth and survival of
Pantaleo stuarti inside the corn flea
beetle insect that
unfortunately we have very limited
knowledge about how Pantelis 20i
interacts with its insect hosts the
beetle has never been successfully
raised their captivity through its
entire lifecycle to establish a breeding
colony what is known is that the
pathways ydi survives in the gut of the
beetle and the intestinal tract and in
overwinters of the beetle and there's
some evidence to suggest that first of
all there is strong evidence that the
type 3 secretion system is important for
the interaction of pantywaist wear day
with its beetle host and there's
suggestion that pant waste where they
actually becomes intracellular within
the epithelial cells of the incites
intestinal tract are the quorum sensing
genes ISA R and ECI essential for growth
in planta we did not identify the quorum
sensing genes through our chance seek
analysis as being essential for growth
and survival and this isn't necessarily
surprising as similar to IRC I say the
mutants that are defective and points
unseen for example those cells that
cannot produce the AHL signal can
actually borrow the signal or steal the
signal from their neighbors and so the
fact that they were not considered
essential actually made some sense to us
and it looks like we have time for one
more question is there a strong
correlation between the bacterial genes
most upregulated in planta and the
bacterial genes considered to be the
most essential for survival and growth
no and this was a big surprise to us we
initially were thinking that there would
be a strong correlation but after
subsequent analysis that kind of makes
sense so for example and our
transcriptome analysis we found that
transporters were highly up regulated
but there were a lot of transporters
therefore the
a mutation in one the song can still
survive because the other ones are being
expressed so therefore any one
transporter was not found to be
essential I would like to once again
thank dr. Stephens for her presentation
I would also like to thank laborat
speaking today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone note that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018 you will
receive an email from lappers letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye